Eric Larsen author of the devil in the
White City you write early in your book
that this book is about the Evanescence
of life what's that mean really what I
was struck by as as the book progresses
my work on the book progressed and and
really when I finally read the the
finished manuscript what I was struck by
is you have all these people working so
hard on this
this vast project the World's Fair and
then suddenly it's over and completely
forgotten and they they put their hearts
and their souls into this thing and that
it disappears I mean literally from from
almost entirely from national memory and
it just seems so there's a certain kind
of sad aspect to that I think but also
very kind of kind of brave and bold you
know humans going into the dark sort of
thing and that's what I mean by the
Evanescence it's there they're here for
that brief time Burnham and his the
architect and his his his colleagues you
know throw all their energy into
building this World's Fair they choose
that course the killer chooses that
course and and both just esli roiled
waters for a brief period of time and
that's over break down the title the
devil in the white city who was the
devil the devil is was a serial killer
named HH Holmes that was his the name he
typically used he was in Chicago in the
eighteen late 1880s and 90s and actually
used the World's Fair of 1893 as a lure
to bring victims to his World's Fair
Hotel which was do-do-do west of the
fairgrounds a short short dry ride it
was as bad as bad gets the devil in the
White City the White City was the
nickname for the World's Fair of 1893
the World's Columbian Exposition in
Chicago White City arose because the
central array of buildings was this
massive array about half a dozen
buildings all painted white so stunning
in fact that when people walked into the
Central Basin of the fair sent the area
around the Central Basin and saw these
buildings that they
they were persistent stories of people
actually bursting into tears just sort
of they had never seen anything quite so
beautiful and the nickname very quickly
arose the white city now the fair itself
was much larger there about 200 other
buildings but that central array is why
it was called the white city where did
you get the idea for this book Oh long
story
I'll give you well I'll give you the
whole story I actually started back in
8th back in 1894 when I was a young man
it started back in 1994 when I read the
Caleb cars the alienist which is a
terrific novel about a fictional serial
killer in old New York and the thing
that I loved about that book was its
evocation of that long past time and you
could just sink into that book it was
marvelous thing I thought to myself I
was in the in the in the search then for
a book idea and I thought well wouldn't
be interesting to try to do a real
historical murder to a nonfiction book
about it a historical murder and trying
to evoke some of the same effect some of
the same sort of sense of the past and
so I actually just quite systematically
began looking for for a good murder to
write about you don't get more
systematic than looking my first book
from the library was the encyclopedia of
murder and so 7 letters in I came to
Holmes they had him under Holmes and I
have to say I read about him I was not
terribly interested in him because he
was so over-the-top bad and I did not
want to do a slasher book I wanted to do
something full of man or something more
Agatha Christie ish and so I continued
looking for other things came across a
murder in New York that had a connection
to a giant hurricane in Texas in 1900
that became I got Star Trek that became
my previous book isaac storm came back
to the world of right early despair
where i was looking for my next idea and
remembered this this idea of doing a
nonfiction murder remembered holmes
still didn't want to do something about
holmes but you know i had nothing else
going on at that point a lot of my ideas
that i had started looking to had fallen
fallen by the wayside and so so I
thought okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna look into the aspect
of this Holmes thing that I hadn't
checked into before which was the
World's Fair started reading about the
World's Fair and fell in love
that's what hooked me but I very very
early on like in the initial conception
of this thing like that first week after
the fair kind of triggered my
imagination I realized that I didn't
want to do still a book about palms
alone nor did I want to do a book about
the fair alone but what struck me
instantly is that the real story is the
two stories together I wouldn't have
wanted to do either alone it's just the
two stories together this this this
almost miraculous in a dark way
juxtaposition of of this heroic act of
civic goodwill the World's Fair the
effort to build it the tremendous odds
against effort to build it and in the
same place at the same time this killer
using this fare to do his his equally
outstanding work at killing it was just
a marvelous juxtaposition to perfect to
ignore has anybody said to you that they
couldn't wait to get through the
chapters on the fair to get to the next
chapter on the murders no in fact it's
it's interesting you guys've that way
what I have found is that people almost
universally have entered the book
thinking oh I'm going to be going to
like this mostly for the serial killer
but they come away liking the fair part
much better and and is that there's a
very there's a very simple reason for
that I think and it has to do with with
the the technical aspects of narrative
and that is that the bernam side of the
story the Daniel burner was the
architect who built the fair who led the
effort to build the fair the bernam side
of the narrative is a classic narratives
the kind of thing you might find in
fictional oh of course it's real because
here's a guy who takes on this
monumental effort against all odds and
truly that was the case I mean when I
started the book I had no conception of
the things that they had things that
would arise to try to stop this effort
to build a fair I mean you know the week
the fair started the nation entered one
of its deepest worst depressions ever
the panic of 1893 and and everybody
expected that that was going to destroy
the fair because nobody could afford to
come it was just one of an array of you
know half a dozen really serious things
that could have could have upset the
whole thing
so it's a classical Nair get into that
store you get into the fight against all
odds to to build this fair and even
though you know the Fair occurred you're
still like wow are they ever going to
pull this off it's kind of like the
allure of a book about the Titanic
because you know it's going to sink and
yet there's always that little question
mark as you're reading through oh is it
really going to sink you know I don't
know why that is it's a it's a marvelous
thing I think about readers that they
had this this element of hope that you
know even against all odds still persist
through a book and that's what sort of
sort of helps us helps us drive a
narrative but that is what I found but
speaking of the Titanic plays a role in
your book plays role in the book yeah
yeah very interesting well at the risk
of giving away something that may be
well I'll give it away but yeah
interestingly after the fair
Daniel Hudson burtom was going to sail
to Europe for a vacation essentially he
was going to sail on a ship called the
Olympic which is the Titanic's twin
sister really at the same time as he was
sailing for Europe his closest friend at
the fair was leaving Europe on the
Titanic his name Greg Millett and as he
was as he was leaving he was leaving
Europe as as Daniel Burnham was sailing
across the sea on his own ship is on
opulent the Olympic what really was this
would have been oh gosh
yeah yeah a year but they was quite a
bit after the fair was much after the
fair 1893 the fair 89 3 is fair this is
this is easily what what is it 15 years
about 14 14 years here right and and
well whatever it is and whatever you're
the Titanic say it's sank we know
there's but but it's I know it's it's
really hard being 49 but the what was
really kind of uncanny about the whole
thing was that Daniel Burnham was
sailing sailing toward Europe his best
friend from the fair is coming back from
Europe and for some unaccountable reason
they talks about this in his diary
Burnham talks about this in this dire
he felt he wanted to send a note to his
friend in the middle of the ocean you
know the using a wireless this was a big
thing in those days because wireless was
still a fairly new concept and it was
just this marvel to be able to
communicate between two ships in the
middle of the ocean something that prior
to you know say 1905 was impossible so
so here they are he gets this impulse to
do it and it's not just something he
makes up after the fact because his
diary has done as he's traveling so we
see it in his diary before all the stuff
happens we see him sending this note we
see him hearing from the steward that
that he was unable to send the note
which is amitis in itself and it turns
out that just as he was sending the note
the Titanic was obviously having its
encounter with it with an iceberg and
this this best last friend of the fair
was was one of the dead there's just
very strange moment it's actually 29
years we'll get it right whatever it was
in the beginning of your book you have
two quotes the first one is make no
little make no little plans they have no
magic to stir men's blood blood Daniel
Burnham director works World's Columbian
Exposition 1893 make no little plans
they have no magic to stir men's blood
why that quote what did I use it why
yeah I think that sums up that there are
two quotes in the front of the book and
I think they both first of all
encapsulate something fundamental about
the two men they capture the
juxtaposition that I think makes the
book work the fact that on the one hand
you have this guy who is devoted to to
to creating he's devoted actually to
civic goodwill to the idea of civic
honor you know this other guy who was
devoted to to murder who was born to
kill so that quote make the little
plants I just think absolutely sums up
what Burnham tried to do and how he
thought in the second go we were just
showing the audiences I was born with
the devil in me I could not help the
fact that I was a murderer no more than
the poet can help the inspiration to
sing dr. HH Holmes confession 1896
Wright who did he confess to well that
was one of many confessions to the
always and actually that confession was
a public confession made through the
Philadelphia Enquirer paid for even back
that paid for by the Philadelphia
Inquirer - well for the Philadelphia
Inquirer was just trying to make make a
stir and grab audience because at the
time this was the single biggest story
in America it's hard to believe because
most people have know nothing about this
killer but they paid for this particular
confession and it was a long long
confession and he was something like 27
pages said and took up I don't know
three or four full newspaper pages of
the Philadelphia Inquirer
but unfortunately like so many of his
confessions and he had probably half a
dozen confessions as as revelations came
out he changed his story he would always
seed his confessions with fact but also
with a liberal amount of fiction the the
funny thing is this was this was really
his last major confession and in it he
claimed to have killed 27 people
unfortunately some of those he claimed
to have killed were still alive he came
forward many of those he claimed to have
killed were infected and were in fact
police did suspect ultimately that he
had done that it is also assumed by the
way that he killed many more than 27 my
guess is probably several dozen over the
course of his life the New York world in
all its its exuberance estimated 200
alone during the fair but I don't I
don't buy that at all it just gives you
a sense of of what people thought about
this guy and how how after the fair when
he was captured the suspicions of what
he had done how they just became just
dominated the American imagination the
jacket says that you're married to a
doctor and live in Seattle and have
three daughters where did it all start
for you wait what all starts your life
my life that's a long start to I've I
was born in Brooklyn New York like half
half of the world I think and and what
year that would have been 1954 in
January where did you go to school to
college I went to University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia
studied what and studied Russian history
Russian culture loved it
and then was actually going to stay and
try to get a job in publishing which I
did as a sort of gofer with the intent
to kind of stay in the vicinity of
writing and meanwhile right on the side
you know that kind of thing and then
made the mistake of seeing all the
President's Men and thought to myself I
got to do that I got to go down I got to
bring down a presidency you know so how
old would you been like 70
that would have been 70 and that would
have been 77 I think depending whatever
the application process would have been
because because I was in the class of
said it would have been 76 because I was
in the class of 77 78 the one that got
out in 78 so yeah it would have been set
late 76 but I think that dates correct
but so I went to Columbia Graduate
School of Journalism I figured I was
gonna apply to one journalism school but
fate take a hand and if I got into that
school and I was I was going to apply
only to the best school if I got in then
the fates were saying I should be a
journalist otherwise I was going to go
to Europe and bum for six months and so
I got in and and began my journalism
career got my first job came back to the
Philadelphia area because I loved
Philadelphia was in Bucks County at the
Bucks County career times just a great
place to start for any reporter who
wants to start out and you know as one
thing led to another I had a sort of an
unfortunate encounter at the paper and
got got got passed over for a promotion
which totally annoyed me so as is often
the case you know when bad things happen
good things happen next I just said I'd
forget it I'm done I'm gonna I gotta
send my resume to all my friends and
other publications and sheer luck struck
and I got a job in Philadelphia with the
Wall Street Journal which then had a
bureau in town and that sort of set me
off on another course and how long we
with the journal in two installments I
would say a total seven years seven to
eight years when did you move to Seattle
mmm six years ago six years ago and when
did you write your first book and what
was it first published book or first
book covers first book was in
the early 90s and that was a book called
the naked consumer and that was a book
about how companies spy on ordinary
Americans and the various techniques
that the use is supposed to be kind of a
funny / spooky look although frankly
given the things that companies can do
today and with email and and the
Internet I mean this my book is nothing
compared to what I could have written
today it was a wonderful book I thought
and I thought was going to be the next
you know Vance Packard sort of thing but
but it turned out to be critically
ignored and public enjoyed it as well
what about lethal passage a lethal
passage was I love that book because it
had a huge impact in the way police
departments thought about how to go
after gun criminals I still to this day
hear about hear from Police Department's
saying you know we loved this book it's
it's helped us think about how to go
after such-and-such a gun dealer and so
forth that was a book about about one
model of handgun I'm not one specific
gun but one model of handgun tracing its
evolution how it how it arose from from
being a weapon designed specifically to
be used by anti-castro guerrillas for
urban where urban warfare in a place
like Havana and how it evolved into
essentially a mass-market consumer
product that became the weapon of choice
for for gun gangs forgetting for drug
gangs and so forth in Baltimore and
other cities that I had been living in
Baltimore at the time one stop along the
way now living in Baltimore at the time
and the thing I was struck by reading
about this was in the 80s late 80s
reading about all these drive-by
shootings was where's a 13 year old kid
get a weapon where's he get a weapon
like this so I essentially traced that
kind of what I like to refer to as the
forces the cultural and institutional
forces that conspired to put this one
one example of this this gun into the
hands of a kid in Virginia Beach
Virginia who used it to kill a teacher
and trace all the forces that
contributed to that the gun culture gun
laws the NRA and so forth it's very it
was very good I think in Isaac's storm
came out what year that would have been
and 98 something like this so and so
great yeah
Isaac storm is probably put my kids
through college yeah it was several
hundred thousand I think so
in this book as we sit here I know where
you've been on the road and this has
been out for a while what most the first
day this book came out first day would
have been February 11th yeah and this
was very this did better than Isaac
storm and I'm very pleased to say give
any numbers and I don't have hard
numbers and actually only one think the
publishing industry has hard numbers
plus it gonna be two three four hundred
thousand that big I think so yeah I mean
the first I you know I'm so vague on
this stuff I try to stay out of the
business of publishing just concentrate
on what I what I do best but the initial
publication publishing run list was
quite large to begin with so that seller
list for how many weeks bestseller list
for I think it was a total of 12 and I
like to think it would have been longer
if the war hadn't started I mean the
book the book got to number one on the
New York Times bestseller list and then
the war started and then again falling
precipitously as as war related books
came up so so on the one hand I found I
feel very lucky to have gotten out
before that debacle well it's my own
opinion but on the other hand you know
it could have been much longer who knows
but I love the book though and that's
what counts
1893 the whether they call the World's
Fair the official name was the World's
Columbian Exposition why that and that
name derives from the fact that the
original conception of the fair was to
have something to honor or commemorate
the 400th anniversary of Columbus's
discovery of America now you say to
yourself wait a minute its 1893 but this
is 1492 that we're talking what happened
well by the time Congress got around to
finally finally deciding which City was
going to have this fair it was too late
to really everybody acknowledged it was
simply too late at that point to have
the fair completed by October 92 which
was when everybody sort of felt would be
the for hunt the official 400th
anniversary so they decided okay we will
dedicate the fair
in October of 1892 but the fair itself
would not open until the until May 1st
1893 but in there there was it was very
interesting the the because the
dedication had to be in October that's
we put a lot of pressure on Daniel
Burnham because the largest building of
the fair this manufactures and Liberal
Arts Building an immense building hard
even to describe to anybody who hasn't
doesn't have a something to compare it
to that building had to be largely done
by the time of the dedication because it
had been decided early on that that was
where the dedication was going to take
place and that building suffered all
manner of disasters along the way I mean
just just a real trial for all the
people who were trying to put this fair
together on the inside right inside the
book you can see this huge map that
you've got of the fair itself and which
one of the buildings are you talking
about it that would be a theater right
that I had there very large large
building gone now of course as are most
of the buildings at what all but one
building from the fair how many
buildings did they build for this earth
the central array was about was about
seven buildings and those were those
were the primary responsibility of
Burnham and Company but the fair itself
had another 200 buildings that they were
all involved in in terms of design
approving designs grading Olmsted
Frederick Law Olmsted was the landscape
architect for the fair he had to he had
to charge of the landscape throughout
the place which itself was one of the
most onerous burdens that anyone at the
fair bore cuz he couldn't really get to
his work until all the other things were
done and they were running late also
tremendous achievement I said that fair
just just a tremendous tremendous event
magical actually how many people went to
it well the the the at the end of the
fair tallies were made and it turned out
that in the six months of the fair it
recorded twenty-eight point five million
visits and you have to put that in
context twenty-eight point five million
visits today that might not seem that
much given the size of the population I
mean what's
sighs of America now 300 million or so
300 million plus in this period the
nation's population is 65 million so
you're recording twenty eight point five
million visits
that's not visit tours there are a lot
of duplicate visits but nonetheless it
gives you a sense of the critical mass
of people who came to this fair and
that's one of the things that made it so
at the time so culturally powerful when
you think about all these people being
in one place at one time then going back
filtering back to their to their
communities the changes in America that
that we even see today were very
powerful that one could argue that you
know here in Washington that that union
station is one in direct offspring of
the fair because the fair made Daniel
Burnham was tremendously influential
architect again though you know that the
sense of his power has has receded from
the national memory I mean we all
remember McKim Charles became we don't
remember Daniel Burnham as much but you
know he wouldn't have gotten that deal
he wouldn't have had that power to make
to do Union Station if not for it's not
for the same holds actually for the
Lincoln Memorial Daniel Burnham was
instrumental in in working out who would
do the design and also what the design
would be and that wouldn't happen also
if he had not become such a powerful
architect after the fair who was macam
by the way Charles McKim was an
architect in New York very famous
architect who was recruited by Burnham
to do a number of buildings at the
World's Fair in Chicago became was a
little reluctant at first ants were many
because you know there was this whole
whole whole thing about Chicago being
this this hog slaughtering backwater and
a lot of these these great famous
architects were a little uneasy about
the idea of doing a project in that hog
slaughtering backwater you know they
wanted to do you know great things that
would last forever but the idea of doing
a fair in Chicago I don't know
it was Burnham sheer power persuasion I
think that brought everybody around and
there's only one building left there's
only one building left and in fact that
takes a certain amount of qualification
because
it is now the museum science of industry
which is a superb museum by the way and
he gorgeous buildings sitting there in
Jackson Park which was the site of the
fair but the Museum of Science and
Industry at the time of the fair was the
Palace of Fine Arts Palace of Fine Arts
however was a temporary building as
we're all the buildings for the fair
decision was made early on that because
there was too little time to build them
out of stone and so forth lasting
materials that they would essentially
have steel frames wood cladding sides
that would be covered with a material
called staff a kind of an exterior
plaster that could be modeled to
resemble stone and modeled very well to
resemble stone so the the Palace of Fine
Arts was built of that material which
did not last a decision was made several
decades after the fair let's save the
structure and rebuild it in permanent
form and that is now the Museum of Fine
Arts I mean the Museum of Science and
Industry and that's really it there are
little bits and pieces though like a
friend of mine went house shopping in
Oak Park and looked at a house that
Frank Lloyd Wright had designed and in
the backyard is a ticket booth from the
fair little outbuilding for this house
all right jumping from the World's Fair
to chloroformed the kiln and the vault
right yeah homes the the serial killer
when he learned he had come to come to
Chicago a few years before the probably
about six years before the fair may I
say how old he was for you guys this is
way that's not his real name either well
his name is said much much it was his
real name muddy imagine yeah is his but
but everybody knows him as dr. HH Holmes
Herman Webster Mudgett Arbonne Webster
Mudgett from where he was originally
from Gilmanton New Hampshire and went
medical school at the University of
Michigan which perhaps was something of
a bit rather most of them might not know
I don't know but he went to went to
medical school there various journeys
around the country eventually wound up
in Chicago
what year in 1886 so there's no fair no
fair that no he has come to Chicago
thinking apparently that I mean nobody
really knows exactly what drove him to
Chicago but but it's clear that it's
clear in retrospect that that given his
personality his psychopathology that he
fed off the very forces that were making
the cities the most powerful things of
that era that were that were driving the
growth of Chicago to become this this
mercantile and industrial powerhouse
that and all these forces associated
with it the anonymity the fact that
women were traveling alone for the first
time in American history because they
were they were coming into the cities
and having jobs as stenographers and
typewriters and so forth so he was drawn
to Chicago for these various reasons I
like to think he was drawing also
because it was the sort of visceral
element of Chicago the blood of the
stockyards the whole thing has just had
to have appealed to a psychopath like
him now what gear how would he have been
again when he first came to town he
would have been in his cowboy he would
have been in his 20s late 20s it was
already a medical doctor already a
medical doctor and already a murderer
has he been married yeah he's been
married and married once left that wife
actually even had a child but but left
them behind in New Hampshire he has come
to Chicago to through to Lou and one
element of his character is that he is
the consummate con man absolutely no
moral core which let him let him do
anything he wanted to do I mean the way
you and I would would would you know in
any sort of business deal would like to
I like to think we would think about the
ethical consequences and it was this a
good thing or a bad thing nothing like
that ever entered this man's brain he
just he was just reacted to situations
and if it took murder to do this fine
it's it's like getting into a cab you
know
so right away he said about conning the
owner of a pharmacy out of her out of
her pharmacy and it's it's it's almost
beyond doubt that he killed her because
she simply she simply disappeared he
said she went to California to Jamie
you're taxing my memory of the book
again he doesn't matter
yeah you think the later there were so
many names him uh she went to California
she went to California and but well she
didn't go to California I mean she went
she went to California with a capital C
I mean she was she was it's very clear
that she was killed because she simply
disappeared from the scene and given
Holmes's later behavior and how he sort
of dodged the question of where she went
it's quite certain that she was she was
killed by him how did he do it
nobody knows how he did that one nobody
knows for sure but it's you know his his
he was a psychopath and as that such he
was sort of a cowardly killer he was not
the kind of person who would go up
behind somebody and slit their throats
or something like that his preferred
weapon was was chloroform in a rag an
overdose of chloroform gas injected into
a room that kind of thing so it's clear
that he would have done that kind of
thing he would not have done the Jack
the Ripper thing let me stop you there
to ask you about you read in cold blood
like Truman Capote how many times before
you wrote your book well in terms of the
whole scope of reading in cold blood
maybe I'm a dark character but I've read
it about six times but before this book
about three two or three times just just
before this book why well you know one
of the problems with with a historical
murder and actually with any murder is
that you know typically there is no
witness there to show what happens when
someone is you know when when the killer
is doing his thing and you know what the
police have to do is kind of piece it
together from from bits and pieces of
evidence and come up with a theory about
exactly how how this happened sort of a
narrative about how the killing occurred
and you know this is something that a
writer has to wrestle with when you're
trying to write especially nonfiction
you have to
these murders you realize at some point
that people that you have responsibility
to your readers to show them what
happened they can't just all be
off-camera so what happened how do you
think this happened how did this murder
come to pass and I didn't know how to do
that I felt it was very necessary to
have some scene some some some way of
bringing us into a couple of the murders
later later in the book it gets a little
wearing to have people just sort of
disappearing off camera you know it's
like like the old super raid videos my
family shot you know people wallets
across may be gone forever you know and
so I read in cold blood because I feel
that Truman Capote did such a powerful
job of capturing those killings and I
wanted to see try yet again to figure
out how he did it
unfortunately every time I read the book
I mean I think myself why could he not
please have left us some footnotes that
would have been just such a wonderful
thing because you don't know with Truman
Capote what's real and what's not
he claimed later that everything was
real except I think the last chapter
which is little odd because the last
chapter is probably the most artificial
of all all the chapters and the most
dead and seems the most real you know so
it's hard to say works so what's your
claim when it comes to your book well
here's what I here's what I took from
from that was that there was there was
you know the sheer power and the way he
manipulated the way he manipulated
scenes you know this year the the
technical aspects of narrative you know
that's about all you can get from Truman
Capote in that book because you just
don't know anything you don't know what
he used and what he what he had access
to so what I came around to finally was
okay I've got a lot of material about
what happens before these killings what
happens afterward theories about what
happens during the killings it occurred
to me that you know if you if you were
to watch a trial on Court TV let's say
obviously child begins on one day and
ends at another and let's say you tuned
in to the middle of this trial as
evidence was being presented without
coaching you would probably have no idea
what that trial is about because
evidence just doesn't fit into neat
containers the way you know writers of
legal thrillers would like them to seem
there are bits and pieces of things
disparity pieces that have to be drawn
together by this this narrative this
prosecutors narrative or defended by the
the defense attorneys narrative and so
really what matters in a trial are is
the opening the opening theory the
opening narrative of how this killing
happened what the prosecutor tells the
jury to begin with that's what puts
everything into a framework so what I
feeling was okay I'm going to take what
I know and build that prosecutors theory
and then in the back of the book
I have copious footnotes I will detail
any kind of intuitive leap that I make
show what information I use where you
can find out information and then you
know you as as the reader if you don't
by my approach to that murder that's
seen then you know you're free to read
through the sources you're free to read
my description of how I came to certain
conclusions and decide for yourself and
I do that in two places for two
particular killings but I don't want to
really reveal because I mean I just this
reads like a suspense novel I don't want
to give too much away about about
killings and what happens but so that
was my approach and I and I'm quite
comfortable with that how much can you
tell us without giving it away about the
use of the vault I could tell you about
the fault yeah because I don't think
that's necessarily the most there's a
lot of other material in the book that I
think is more toward the end is more
compelling
I gotta admit to that when I read this
book I said I got a problem here he
isn't going to talk about this you know
and rarely the books that we have here
that those kind of situations because
and I wondered I wanted to ask you as
long as we're right there
what have you decided to do over these
months when people ask you about the
book how far do you go see III have III
have to be frank I have I have I have a
real difficulty talking about certain
elements of the book like whenever I do
public talks I talk mostly about the
fair because see my I met my goal in
doing a
look like this is to create something
that that I would love and I think
readers love also and that's the
feedback I'm getting and that is to
create this this moment where you you
begin the book you begin reading the
book and if I've done my job right you
sink into that book and you're not going
to emerge from that book until you're
done hopefully you know early in the
morning the next day you know you've
read straight through which a lot of
people apparently have done or at least
you finished it fairly quickly and and
and that you just sort of felt yourself
lost in this past world and that you
emerge from this past world feeling
different maybe even feeling a certain
longing for the past which I've heard a
lot from people which I that I really
loved I had one woman talk in Chicago
stand up nearly in tears telling me how
much she loved the book and how she
didn't want it to end that's the sort of
feeling I wanted to kind of conjure in
this thing I want it to be traditional
you know dry nonfiction where you know
you just sort of force yourself to read
it because it's interesting but there's
no story there so it's a real problem
then to talk about things that that that
are coming in the book that I've spent a
lot of effort trying to trying to reveal
them in an artful way without violating
the tenets of what's fact reveal them in
an artful way and then and and and
somehow cope when people say well so
tell us about the serial killer what
happened at this point what happened at
this point I was doing a radio interview
of on NPR with Scott Simas one of my
favorite all-time interviewers and he
said at one point he said now could I
could I ask you to read this passage and
I said no I mean I didn't want to read
the passage that he wanted because it
was too important to one element of the
book so and I'm I have to look out for
for readers above all I just hate to
give stuff away but having said that I
can talk a little about the ball where
was the ball what was in Holmes's hotel
and it was a not his hotel room but is
it this hotel he owned yeah let's dress
that yeah I was getting to the swinger
there actually before let's finish that
up first that
he came to Chicago managed through
various machinations to acquire some
land to build a three-story structure
when he learned that the fair was going
to be located amazingly very near him in
Jackson Park due due east of his hotel
just a short trolley ride a matter of
blocks
he began converting his building into
this hotel into a hotel with with guest
rooms and so forth but it also had
certain other features it had it had a
crematorium it had a it had dissection
table lime kilns acid vats it also had
this vault and what this was was was a
very carefully constructed room
essentially size of a walk-in bank vault
airtight with a addition of a gas jet
that would allow him to admit gasps you
know conventional natural gas into the
room and suffocate anybody who was in
there or if he wanted to you know
prolong the murder of somebody in that
vault he just simply shut the door and
you know listen in the next room which
was his office as that person succumbed
to lack of oxygen and panic and so forth
so that's essentially what the vault was
you have a footnote for instance under
acquiring many I base my conclusions
about Holmes's motivation on studies of
Psychopaths conducted throughout the
20th century Holmes behavior his
swindles his multiple marriages his
extraordinary charm his lack of regard
for the differences between right and
wrong and is almost eerie ability to
detect weakness and vulnerability and
others fits with uncanny precision
descriptions of the most extreme sorts
of psychopaths and you go into some
great detail there did you talk with any
psychologists or psychiatrists to
understand the behavior I'll tell you
one of the things that when I finished
the first draft of the book I didn't I
didn't love it I mean I thought parts of
it were very good especially the fair
part but there was still something about
the killing part that eluded me when was
the first
would you finish that first how memory
questions let's see probably nine months
before the book came out so so nine
months urban and while I'm on it
drop back how long did it take you to
physically write the book about a year
and a half year and a half and you had
all your research done and you're into
the writing most the research done let's
say I'd say 7/8 of the research done and
then the writing took about a year and a
half how many days a week
Oh what I'm writing when I'm actually
into the project it's every day how many
words a day I don't go by words here's
how I operate I get up when I'm when I'm
writing I get up at about 4:00 and and
that's that's my favorite writing time
and I write until about 7:00 7:30
depending on what day it is if it's a
weekend day I may go on straight through
til til 9:00 because the kids are
sleeping in and my wife is not going to
work and all that stuff during the
weekday it's you know 4 7 4 2 7 4 to
6:30 and I try to write a couple of
pages
I'm not firm I don't have a specific
goal the one thing I always adhere to
you though is that I I stop while I'm
ahead
if if I'm going to take that break for
breakfast I may stop in the middle of a
sentence or the middle of the paragraph
something I know how to finish because
as any writer knows it's the that's what
that's what kills you is when you just
don't know what to do when you come back
and all all the demons accumulate and
then you go out for a cappuccino that
kind of thing but then after breakfast
I'll come back to working and I'll try
and do a couple of pages more again
being sure to stop in the middle of a
paragraph in the middle of a sentence
something I know with absolute certainty
has an easy finish the next morning
early on with any book that I've written
I find that it's it's agonizingly slow
at first phase I make it a page Don
maybe
just a couple of paragraphs than the
second part of the morning maybe maybe
finish up one page it may go like that
for a month
and then suddenly you're doing two pages
a day and then at the end of the project
I find sometimes I'm working from four
till six and I may do ten pages a day
because you get this acceleration effect
the psychiatrist when did you finally
get that yes so so so I had I had
finished the manuscript and I just was
not happy with the whole motivation
thing but we know Holmes did these
things and the problem again with
historical stuff is you don't have the
FBI's behavioral section doing reams of
material on what drove this guy so here
he's doing all these things he's clearly
a sinister character but what is it
that's driving him so I gave the
manuscript to to a forensic psychiatrist
in Seattle to read he read it very
quickly we had a very interesting lunch
breakfast a few days after that in which
he essentially diagnosed this character
and from from his telling from what I
presented in the book it was clear to
him that the guy was so-called
full-blown psychopath now officially
it's like I just don't use the term
Psychopaths anymore they used the term
antisocial personality disorder however
you get a psychiatrist alone and he says
psycho psychopath I mean that's what it
was but psychopathy people have people
really I think there is a widespread
misunderstanding of what a psychopath is
based on things like like Hitchcock's
movie psycho and about you know slasher
movies and so forth true psychopath of
this character is a guy with who simply
has no moral core I mean to impute
certain kinds of evil designs and so
forth is is kind of beyond the actual
the actual disorder it's more like he
does this almost mechanistically this is
the sort of who he is he doesn't have to
think about being evil he doesn't have
to contrive to being evil it's just what
he does and when you're like that it's a
very powerful position to be in because
you can do anything and that's why he
got away with it you can you can
convince anyone of anything because you
don't have that sort of more
we'll break that allows people to detect
deception do you know what I mean you're
just you're just openly bad and you can
make in in that context you can just you
can seem like anything you can seem like
the most charming man in the world which
he did and one of the things that you
find the psychiatrist
steered me to a lot of very interesting
literature about Psychopaths and this
was these were characters by the way who
were not well understood
not at all understood in the 19th
century and arguably very poorly
understood in the first few decades of
the 20th this is the understanding of
psychopaths was a fairly new you know
turns out the long sweep of history is a
fairly new sort of thing but the
literature that this guy steered me to
was fascinating because there were
passages that could have described
Holmes perfectly including references
continued repeated references to this
this uncanny ability to seduce women go
figure
I who understands this stuff but that
that came up repeatedly in the
literature this this almost supernatural
ability to to seduce women I kind of
wish I had it I'd you know I was out
that I did when I was single I want to
come back to the end but just like you
do in the book every other chapter
basically deals with the two different
stories the the known things that happen
around the World's Fair like the George
Ferris wheel yeah
the ferris wheel Cracker Jack Walt
Disney's father I mean it just goes on
what are Samuel Gompers the union
organizer how much other things came out
of this fair oh you see that was one of
the that was the magic of the fair and
what really ultimately persuaded me to
do the book was that you had all these
two it really was as if some I hate to
keep resorting to the term supernatural
it was almost as if there was some some
extra real force that brought everything
together at this time I mean this was
just such an amazing affair and you met
you mentioned just a few of the things
that arose from it you know even even
for example the Wizard of Oz the Emerald
City is thought to have
actually quite direct routes in the
white city of the fair because l frank
baum and his artists were had gone to
the fair and admired the fair and and in
fact is even there's even some theory
that you know in the in the book
apparently the emerald city is actually
what you see once you put on your green
glasses it's not green to begin with
it's a white city and you put on your
glasses and it becomes green and and
that's kind of fascinating to think
about because they here's the white city
on the lake there was that there was
dreaded weak shredded wheat and
Shimomura's pancakes is another thing
which is a shocking product because you
know a whole meal in a box Marshall
Field Clarence Darrow George
Westinghouse Thomas Edison Henry Adams
Archduke Francis Ferdinand the Eiffel
Tower that when I mentioned George first
the ferris wheel
yeah what was the contest okay yeah the
and this is something that I actually
protected for a long time and I did
going back to my my feelings about
narrative and so forth I actually fought
tooth and nail with the marketing
department at crown not to say anything
about the ferris wheel
because because of the way I presented
as the sort of secret thing that came
out of the fair but that's been so
widely blown anyway that I don't care I
can talk about it what happened was and
part of actually the the reason the
World's Fair of 1893 even came to be was
because prior to that in Paris there had
been the great Paris Universal
Exposition tremendous tremendous thing
the most amazing thing anybody had seen
prior to the 1893 Fair in Paris of
course and one of the amazing things
there was the Eiffel Tower this 1,000
foot structure done by by Eiffel and
it's hard to imagine today what a 1,000
foot structure would have seemed like at
that time but it was monumental you get
that sense when you see photographs of
the Eiffel Tower you even to this day it
rises above everything but this was a
tremendous thing at the Paris faire also
the French really pulled out all the
stops to humiliate everybody else who is
exhibiting there and and we from United
States kind of did our own share had our
own part in that because we just
presented this absolutely lackluster
lame thing and so what resulted was this
kind of kind of feeling like we got to
get back at the French you see this
French American thing has been with us a
long time
and that was one of the one of the
motivating factors that made people say
yes let's do this fair to commemorate
Columbus's discovery of America and
we'll use this to stick it to the French
well one of the things that Burnham as
the head of the effort to to to do the
World's Fair in Chicago really felt
necessary was them but that Chicago the
fair would need some kind of engineering
monument to supersede eiffel's tower and
he felt pretty clearly that it should
not just be another tower in fact Eiffel
himself sent a proposal to build the
tower for the Chicago fair and it was
after some consideration rejected you'll
be bigger when there's gonna be bigger
yes
he's always going to be bigger but it
was that the concept was rejected and so
the search then went on for for
something else in fact at one point
Burnham directly challenged a group of
engineers at a at a an engineering Club
that met Chicago on a weekend afternoon
too he challenged them he said he said
you know the architects of America have
come through with flying colors for this
fair the engineers have not you know
essentially saying hey what's wrong with
you guys
and one of the people in the audience
that day was George Washington Gail
Farris who was of course the man who
created the ferris wheel now the thing
he had had this idea Ferriss and had
this idea in his mind for a while this
idea of a revolving essentially a
revolving a giant revolving wheel that
people could actually ride and I've been
just bumping around his head he was a
steel inspection engineer from from
Pittsburgh who had the steel inspection
contract for the World's Fair suddenly
Burnham's brooms challenge kind of
galvanized and said well okay how about
this
they've leaded to Burma and Brad first
rejected it because it looked too too
deadly him as this this very elegant
design but it didn't look like it could
withstand Chicago wins anything but
after a point and after doing some
scrupulous Lee
precise drawings hiring an engineer to
do them Faris won the concession from
the World's Fair and ultimately created
this gigantic ferris wheel and it's very
hard to conceive today how big this
thing was
it had 36 cars each car carried 60
people sick so think about that 60
people per car on this ferris wheel it
was massive anything been built like
that since well there is a there is a
ferris wheel in Vienna and that is about
3/4 the size but is said to be a replica
of the ferris wheel and then there's the
what's it called one in London the
London Eye ferris wheel which is it's
not as large even as the one of the fair
now I've got to ask you a question about
my hometown because I'm reading along
and all of a sudden one of the women
yeah that dr. Holmes you know I put this
gets his hands on is his accurate even
least from my hometown of Lockett India
actually well in the end I decide never
heard the name before I didn't how to
pronounce it is it emmeline to start
with yes and the last name is a grand
you know yeah I would say so grand see
you saying she granted it's a grave it's
C I gr a.m. but there are there are
questions by the way about a lot of the
pronunciations because nobody knows
anymore yeah nobody but I never seen the
name you know it's a fairly small town
but and there and her father was a
doctor I believe yes yes how did she get
inside his little web Emmeline segrand
yeah well she had she had gone to work
at this famous alcohol rehab place in
duel that wasn't white Dwight yeah
Illinois yeah and it was very famous
place actually at that time that's
another one of those sort of funny
things about about doing a nonfiction
book is you come across all these
bizarre things that a novelist could
never make up I mean here's this Dwight
Institute which was absolutely bizarre I
mean would inject you numerous times a
day with this sort of bizarre
combination of of multi luridly colored
colored chemicals and so forth and and
and and you know over time supposedly
this just dried you out and i think gold
was one key element of the thing the
gold cure anyway she had been working
there and apparently an assistant of
holmes is the sky potential had gone to
two homeless had sent him to dwight to
dry out sort of a remarkable act of
generosity by holmes but but the guy has
working for him yeah
but as readers will find he doesn't do
anything just for for the sake of good
cuz he's got a reason any weight
potential meets Emmeline segrand there
that the Dwight Institute in Emily
Instagram by all accounts was was
stunning
quite quite young very beautiful and
testings back a story but but this this
newly angelic woman at Dwight and then
Holmes
you never want to miss an opportunity
writes to her and says look why don't
you come work for me you know I've heard
about you from Tetzel and I'll pay you
of this terrific salary come on
so she comes out works for him and
certain bad things happen and the if I
remember the doctor her father comes to
visit yeah yeah checks out dr. Holmes
yep checks out dr. Holmes and in many
ways and again here I come back to not
going to give too much away but but in
many ways the the story of Emmaline's
granddaughter
yeah we're running out of time and we
haven't given anything away yeah you
know you've done a good job of not I
hate that but but dr. Holmes did write a
memoir you say Holmes wrote a memoir
fascinating memoir which is actually in
the rare book section here at the
Library of Congress and what's very
interesting about that memoir is that it
has a lot of good biographical detail
that seems to check out based on what
other you know reporters back in the era
when this was being heavily covered for
digging up about him
it's got a lot of good biographical
material got a lot of good detail that
checks out it also has this underlying
skein of absolute barefaced deception so
it's fascinating fascinating read and
you say you didn't use a researcher I
don't use researchers you did it all
yourself I did it all myself and the
reason I should I give a researcher all
the fun I mean to me the fun is this is
going to sound I'm sure people out there
are cringing say my god this guy likes
libraries and I do I mean to me every
day you know in a great archive or a
library is like a small detective story
and I just love getting my hands on on
literally getting my hands on bits and
pieces of the past what's next well I'm
currently thrashing around looking for
the next thing and I have I have an idea
that that I think is going to go but I
would be a fool to even mention it dot
even come close not even come close
except to say that it will be it will be
a historical narrative it will be not to
be excessively coy either it will be
within 10 to 15 years of the turn of the
19th into the 20th century but what is
this on the cover right here that is the
administration building in the White
City at the World's Fair the tall
buildings spread out from there are yeah
by the way 1893 how long did it last six
months May 1st to the end of October and
we're out of time Eric Larsen has been
our guest and the book is called the
devil in the White City the Chicago
World's Fair 1893 and the story of dr.
Holmes thank you very much thank you